so in a big part of what I focus on at
any given time is you know making sure
we are innovating and building products
for the future one brilliant invention
can unleash other entrepreneurs to
revolutionize industries in ways you
could never predict we want to push the
technology at times because you don't
know what's possible on the other side
you have to work with people where you
feel a bit insecure that's essential
because that means you're working with
people who are better than you
he's an Indian American business
executive he's the current CEO of Google
he has an estimated net worth of 1
billion dollars he sundar Pichai and
here's my take on his top 10 rules for
success rule number seven is my personal
favorite and mercury's to figure out
which one you guys like the best also as
you're watching if he says something
that really hits you hard really means a
lot to you leaving the comments and put
quotes around it so other people can be
inspired as well from one perspective
and I think it's true for technology in
particular you know the world keeps
changing as I said earlier so in a big
part of what I focus on at any given
time is you know making sure we are
innovating and building products for the
future you know it's just got to be a
normal course of how you think and so
you know we're constantly thinking about
what to do next so you know Android is
very popular people are using smart
phones but you know I always didn't
think about what is the next version of
how people use computing right and so we
are thinking about you know things like
virtual reality or augmented reality so
these are all new areas but we are
constantly thinking about it and so you
have to do that on a constant basis to
push forward the thing which attracted
me to Google and to Internet in general
is that it's a great equalizer right and
so to me always being struck by the fact
that Google search work the same mm-hmm
if as long as you had access to computer
with connectivity if you were a rural
kid anywhere or if you were a professor
at Stanford or Harvard
and and to me you know I want Google to
strive to push to do that not just build
technology for a certain segments right
for me it's it matters that you know we
drive technology as a as an equalizing
force as an enabler to everyone around
the world growing up in India like many
of you I got my first telephone when I
was 12 in my case it turned out to be a
rotary phone so it wasn't that great for
selfies but I still loved to call my
friends play with it and sometimes take
it apart that telephone cemented my
fascination with technology I remember
in my parents house in Chennai reading
about the invention of the transistor at
Bell Labs of course that initial
invention helped found what became known
as Silicon Valley and out of that came
companies like fascial semiconductor and
Intel and all the computers and software
that we all used today you can draw a
direct line from that invention to the
technology that powers your Twitter feed
or your reach ad messages today I
remember reading about that I'm thinking
it's the idea that matters it didn't
matter where you come from or what your
background is one revolutionary idea one
brilliant invention can unleash other
entrepreneurs to revolutionize
industries in ways you could never
predict you'll have many of many many
opportunity opportunities to reinvent
yourself and so you know so I think you
know it's worthwhile taking risks on
trying to do something you're really you
know excited by and if the first attempt
you don't do it you know you can try
again and you know things tend to work
out in the long run in Silicon Valley
you know you know Paulo Ruiz and so many
people's start up with companies
starting up a company and even having
failed you can wear it like a badge of
honor right and I think that's important
you know culturally you know risk is
rewarded I remember when I started
working at Google you know I if I went
and you know people were discussing
ideas to other people who heard the
ideas try to build on those ideas they
encouraged
such a culture of optimism it's a
culture of risk-taking and I think
that's really important so are there any
Jedi mind tricks that you're employing
that you know maybe people aren't seeing
that you're doing to motivate your
employees you know for me mainly is I've
always been very passionate so you know
I'm an optimist about how technology can
make a difference and so I focus on that
then that way you can tend to forget
about the other things the rest is noise
so in some ways we believe that software
is at a stage where you know software
increasingly is playing a more and more
critical role in solving things which it
didn't before okay so to me when I look
at cars people's going to inordinate
amount of time in cars these are
resources which are very poorly utilized
right now as we speak you know you can
look outside and you can see all the
cars which are proud of their cars
weren't we ready to get here is just
sitting in the parking lot right so they
can use less than 10% so we see these
problems and we see okay can we solve it
at scale and just computing play a part
in it software and computer science and
while the effort may seem ambitious or
crazy you know we take a very
disciplined approach inside right you
know so those are taught through like
businesses which we are building and
it's just to be able to take a long term
view but we run them in a very
disciplined way our research can be
longer term and we do that precisely in
research you know when we take research
projects like Google a tap or a core
research we never know whether some of
them even makes viable business
applications but we want to push the
technology at times because you don't
know what's possible on the other side
being in the u.s. you know I find people
take a remarkably very number of paths
and you know so I do think it's
important to follow your dream and do
something which you're you know excited
by you know so I think if you follow
your heart and do what you like you will
always do much better and so I don't
think it matters that you're an engineer
or
you're you know you're in science or it
could be any field
what is your morning routine like what
do you do when you first get up in the
morning you know believe it or not I
still you know I read a physical paper
every single morning that's fine I read
The Wall Street Journal every morning I
read the New York Times online and you
know I still I'm very particular about
having my tea it's very English you know
I grew up in India so having my tea and
I'm vegetarian so I need to get my
protein so I always have an omelet in
the morning with toast tea and read my
paper so I do that every morning times
you wake up 6:30 to 7:00
so that's when I do it do you exercise
in the morning no later in the day
sometimes you know if I get a chance but
always in the evening I wish I could do
it in the morning I'm not a morning
person so I need my time with my paper
and tea to wake up and kind of get going
now you're being spoken about as a
potential xeu Google I keep hearing that
I mean Larry is very very committed to
Google for the very long term so am I am
passionate about computing and you know
Google gives a chance for me to do what
I love and do it in a way which impacts
a lot of people and so it's a good
partnership I have with Larry and with
the team there and so you know I
expected to stay to say you know I would
actually encourage all of you you know
if at some point in your life you know
you have to work with people where you
feel a bit insecure that's essential
because that means you're working with
people who are better than you and we're
pushing you right and so I always
encourage if you if you actually feel
very secure in what you do you know that
means you're doing something comfortable
and you're not pushing yourself and so
there are many many times I've felt
working with people in a group am i
doing enough these people seem much
better than me and I think I think
that's a inherent part of learning thank
you guys so much for watching I made
this video because yeah she van asked me
to so if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next leave
it down in the comments below and I'll
see what I can do I'd also love to know
which of the top ten rules had the
biggest impact on you and why leave in
the comments I'm going to join in the
discussion finally I want to give a
quick shout out to Jonathan Chu from
choose joy comm Jonathan thank you so
much for buying my book it really means
a lot to me those you watching if you
want your chance at a shout out in a
future video make sure to pick up a copy
of the book and email in your receipt so
you can keep track thank you guys so
much for watching continue to believe or
whatever you're one where it is and I'll
see you soon